[Música]
el kremlin está crujiendo por dentro el
intento de golpe de estado del grupo
Wagner encabezado por jefgen y pregosin
ha dejado muy tocado a Vladimir Putin
por primera vez ha quedado claro que el
presidente ruso ya no es un tipo tan
fuerte ni su gobierno tiene tanto
control como antaño en poco más de un
año Vladimir Putin ha pasado de ser un
líder fuerte y temido prácticamente el
nuevo zar de la Rusia moderna a
convertirse en una especie de líder
paria de un país que se cae a pedazos la
guerra va mal Las bajas se acumulan y
ahora los señores de la guerra se
atreven incluso a retarle al kremlin
seamos honestos hace dos años este
escenario nos hubiera parecido
completamente descabellado pero cuando
te lanzas a una guerra como la de
Ucrania si no la ganas entonces puedes
tener muchos problemas a nadie le gusta
perder y no lo dudéis siempre tiene que
haber un culpable por eso aquí en
visualpolitik ya os contamos como tras
los fracasos y el esfuerzo de Rusia en
la guerra contra Japón y también en la
Primera Guerra Mundial se produjo la
revolución de febrero de 1917 y no no
estamos hablando de la Revolución
bolchevique hablamos de la que tuvo
lugar meses antes que no fue una
revolución comunista sin una Revolución
liberal cuando estalló el zar intentó
sofocar la revuelta por la fuerza pero
las guarniciones militares de San
Petersburgo se sublevaron y
desobedecieron las órdenes recibidas una
semana después Nicolás II abdicó veis
algún paralelismo
vale que el grupo Wagner no es el
ejército y Que de momento el presidente
de Rusia no ha tenido que abdicar pero
Es evidente que los paralelismos están
sobre la mesa y ojo no lo decimos
nosotros lo dice el propio Putin en el
mensaje a la nación que pronunció
mientras el golpe de mano de gibgen y
pregosin estaba en marcha fijaos esto
nos extrañe y
Misión
y ojo porque la revolución de 1917 no es
el único paralelismo histórico que
podemos encontrar con la situación
actual existe otro acontecimiento mucho
más reciente que nos recuerda mucho a
todo lo que estamos viviendo tras el
fracaso de Rusia en Ucrania pero lo
veremos más adelante en el vídeo de hoy
por cierto que si queréis todos los
detalles del golpe de pregosing contra
Putin los tenéis en un vídeo que os
dejamos aquí abajo en la descripción
Porque las preguntas que hoy nos hacemos
son Cómo podría ser una Rusia post
Vladimir Putin quién podría sustituirla
en el cargo Qué consecuencias políticas
puede tener el pulso hecho por los
Wagner realmente ha podido debilitar a
Putin si al final que todo quedó en nada
vamos a responder a estas preguntas pero
antes si te gusta lo que hacemos y
quieres ayudarnos a crecer puedes
sumarte a nuestra comunidad de patreon
además de contribuir con este proyecto
también recibirás un montón de contenido
extra como el boletín las claves de la
semana y merchandising exclusivo Muchas
gracias a los que ya nos estáis echando
una mano formando parte de la comunidad
y ahora sí vamos a ver un poco de
historia
la caída del Imperio rojo
si algo nos dice la historia de Rusia es
que en este país los cambios de gobierno
y la lucha por la influencia política no
suelen ser acontecimientos para nada
tranquilos conspiraciones
envenenamientos muertes extremadamente
casuales golpes de estado y muchas
muchísimas tradiciones tenemos ejemplos
para todos los gustos desde la expulsión
de Trotsky a manos de stalin a la
destitución de hussef promovida por
leónidas Brunet o el calvario que vivió
gorbachov que terminó provocando el fin
de la mismísima unión soviética echamos
un vistazo a este último caso en 1991 la
unión soviética estaba en crisis el
Imperio comunista parecía cada vez más
agotado el entonces líder soviético
Michael gorbachov había iniciado un
proceso de reforma que incluía la
aprobación de la prehistórica esto es la
reestructuración económica pero también
de la glass nost que significa la
apertura política
estos cambios fueron toda una Revolución
pusieron punto final a muchos de los
cimientos del viejo modelo soviético lo
que por supuesto No gustó a todo el
mundo muchos miembros del partido
comunista del ejército y de los
servicios de inteligencia vieron estos
cambios como una traición a los
principios soviéticos y como además la
población estaba sufriendo una durísima
crisis económica los rusos tampoco
parecían particularmente emocionados con
gorbachov
querida comunidad de visualpolitik el
modelo hacía aguas y en agosto de 1991
un grupo de altos funcionarios conocidos
Como comité Estatal de emergencia
intentó dar un golpe de estado para
tomar las riendas deshacer las reformas
de gorbachov y Volver al viejo modelo
soviético Sin embargo a pesar de que el
golpe tenía bastantes apoyos dentro del
estado al final fracasó el entonces
vicepresidente ruso Boris y jugó un
papel fundamental para que el golpe no
triunfara subido literalmente en un
tanque llamó a la resistencia civil
contra El golpe los moscovitas
respondieron y el golpe fracasó en tres
días pese a ello el poder de gorbachov
había sido gravemente diezmado tanto que
en los meses siguientes las diferentes
repúblicas que conformaban la unión
soviética empezaron a pasar
olímpicamente de Moscú al final el 26 de
diciembre de ese mismo año apenas cuatro
meses después del golpe se produjo la
disolución completa de La Unión
soviética El Imperio rojo era ya
historia El golpe del 19 de agosto
fracasó pero al mismo tiempo terminó por
provocar el hundimiento completo de La
mismísima Unión de repúblicas
socialistas soviéticas Pues bien el que
ahora en tiempos también muy difíciles
para Rusia Se ha producido la primera
insurrección Armada contra Putin un
intento de golpe de estado que parece
haber fracasado pero realmente ha sido
así hasta qué punto está en riesgo la
continuidad de Vladimir Putin estamos
ante un escenario similar al del golpe
que fracasó en 1991 Pues ahora mismo lo
vamos a ver
[Música]
escenario que apunta alto
de momento el primer invite contra
Vladimir Putin ya se ha producido y lo
ha liderado este hombre que veis en
pantalla y que estoy seguro de que todos
conocéis jeffganish el fundador y el
líder del grupo de mercenarios Wagner un
tipo y hasta la Guerra de Ucrania era un
completo desconocido al menos para el
gran público Lo cierto es que pregosin
es un viejo Aliado de Vladimir Putin que
Durante los últimos años se ha dedicado
a desarrollar una enorme red de
tentáculos al servicio de Vladimir Putin
y ojo porque ha sido muy útil
por ejemplo cuando el presidente ruso
lanzó su invasión de Ucrania quiso
asegurarse que la guerra no creara
Héroes nacionales capaces de rivalizar
con su figura de esta forma cuando en
verano del 2022 el general Alexander
lapin empezó a ser relativamente popular
automáticamente se lo quitaron de en
medio para desacreditarle en redes Putin
recurrió al grupo Wagner que además de
repartir mercenarios por el mundo
también tiene una importante división
para propagar fake news y librar la
guerra mediática
luego cuando el ejército ruso estaba
completamente atascado y era incapaz de
lograr ninguna Victoria en Ucrania Putin
recurrió otra vez a los Wagner para que
lograron hacerse consolidar primero y
con bahamut después cosa que
consiguieron
Wagner fue el único elemento exitoso de
la invasión rusa Durante un año y su
éxito fue muy limitado y se centró en
una pequeña ciudad y sus tácticas fueron
bárbaras incluso para el personal de
Wagner Pero al menos lograron algo el
ejército ruso no podía andris agoron ex
ministro de defensa de Ucrania el caso y
esto es Quizás lo más sorprendente de
toda esta historia es que si bien Putin
quería asegurarse de que la Guerra de
Ucrania no creara potenciales rivales al
final terminó facilitando que el propio
líder del grupo wagnesis hiciera muy
popular tan popular que a comienzos de
año ya había periodistas y analistas que
lo veían como todo un candidato a
suceder al propio Putin podemos decir
que pregosin se pasó todas las pantallas
y adelantó a la inmensa mayor parte de
los gerifaltes y oligarcas de Rusia
había hecho mucho dinero había logrado
muchísimo poder tenía un ejército
privado y encima empezaba a ser bastante
popular tanto entre el ejército como
entre la mismísima sociedad rusa
[Música]
su meteórico ascenso comenzó en el
verano del 2022 cuando recorrió las
prisiones rusas para reclutar
prisioneros para su ejército privado
ofrecía indultos a todos aquellos presos
que lucharan en primera línea en Ucrania
seis meses de servicio y luego libertad
además como ya os contamos en el
anterior vídeo sobre la situación en
Rusia tras el golpe de los wagners sin
tampoco ha dudado en grabar vídeos
condenando la pérdida de soldados rusos
ha hecho regalos a sus vidas y a sus
madres y sobre todo ha dicho verdades
sobre la guerra que nadie más se atrevía
a decir en Rusia
Asimismo Haber puesto en la Diana de sus
feroces críticas al mismísimo ministro
de defensa sergei y al jefe del Estado
Mayor el general valerígeras ha sido de
gran ayuda para ganarse la imagen de ser
un guerrero efectivo e independiente
todo un portavoz de la Rusia fuerte y
grande que Putin siempre defendió pero
ahora Parece ser aguas de esta forma
durante el 2023 pregosin se ha
preocupado cada vez más de representar y
defender los intereses de los soldados
rusos probablemente está popularidad sea
la razón por la que nadie en el kremlin
se haya atrevido a perseguirle Pese a
que haya empezado un interrupción armada
fijaos por ejemplo en lo que decía ya En
enero de 2023 el periodista ruso
mijailgar 26 de enero de 2023 en un
futuro próximo El señor pregotzin puede
desafiar al presidente y es posible que
el señor Putin ya no pueda oponerse a su
chef mijail sigar todo una premonición
no os parece Claro que pregón puede no
ser el único ni tal vez el principal
candidato a suceder a Putin queréis
conocer más nombres pues atentos
[Música]
quién podría suceder a Putin
quién podría suceder al emperador Esta
es probablemente la pregunta más
importante y al mismo tiempo más difícil
de responder en este momento pensadlo
bien si hace seis meses nos hubieran
dicho que pregosin También conocido como
el chef de Putin iba a traicionar al
presidente ruso probablemente nos lo
hubiéramos creído y sin embargo todos
vimos como sus tropas y vehículos
incluyendo algunos tanques avanzaban
hacia Moscú Pues bien Exactamente lo
mismo puede ocurrir en otro momento con
otras muchas personas un jefe de la
guerra un oligarque importante un
militar de alto Rango o simplemente
algún burócrata que hasta ahora haya
pasado desapercibido desde luego si
Putin cae no será porque voluntariamente
decida jubilarse en su mega palacio del
mar Negro que por cierto es este que
veis en Google Maps pero no nos
desviemos si Putin se jubila no será por
voluntad propia sino por obligación por
las buenas o por las malas y ahí puede
surgir Cualquier nombre y desde luego el
del propio jeffeny pregosin podría ser
uno de ellos sin embargo las elecciones
rusas están como quien dice a la vuelta
de la esquina se tiene que celebrar en
marzo de 2024 Así que si os parece vamos
a hacer un pequeño juego
[Música]
supongamos que el régimen actual
consigue mantener el control a toda
Costa y que los actuales círculos de
poder en torno Putin quieren mantener
precisamente eso su poder supongamos por
último que llegan a la conclusión de que
Putin ya está muy quemado cosa bastante
obvia y que necesitan una cara nueva ojo
esto no parece algo tan descabellado con
tantísimos fracasos políticos militares
y económicos Esta puede ser una
conclusión bastante lógica cambiar la
cara del mandamás antes de que otros
quieran cambiar el régimen al completo
por supuesto esto es todo una enorme
conjetura pero es una conjetura que
puede sernos muy útil para saber qué
nombres podríamos encontrar sobre la
mesa es decir cuáles son los nombres que
hoy por hoy suenan con más fuerza o
parecen más probables para llevar a cabo
una transición continuista por ejemplo
ahí tenemos a nikolai patroussef que es
amigo de Putin desde su época como
agente de la kgb Y actualmente es
Secretario del Consejo de Seguridad de
la federación de Rusia su mayor hándicap
que mantiene posturas muy radicales
sobre el mantenimiento de la Guerra de
Ucrania De hecho hay quienes alegan que
es una de sus máximos promotores otro
nombre podría ser el de Dimitri mefveth
probablemente os suene este nombre
Porque en vez ya fue presidente febrero
de Rusia entre 2008 y 2012 básicamente
presidente florero para que Putin
pudiera seguir mandando sin saltarse los
límites que fijaba la Constitución es un
tipo muy próximo a Putin y es bastante
más joven 57 años frente a 70
actualmente es vicepresidente del
Consejo de Seguridad de Rusia sin
embargo tiene dos problemas por un lado
su popularidad y su imagen quedaron muy
tocados al verse envuelto en un Macro
caso de corrupción que desveló el líder
opositor alexey navaldi el ruso medev
vinculado a un imperio inmobiliario de
mil millones de euros que sí que todos
sabemos que Rusia y corrupción son
prácticamente sinónimos pero pese a todo
esto que queréis que os diga eso de ver
que el Primer Ministro tiene un montón
de palacios dinero y que utiliza
constantemente los helicópteros del
gobierno para sus asuntos personales
no da muy buena imagen ni siquiera en
Rusia Por otra parte en los últimos años
Mercedes ha dado un giro de 180 grados a
su discurso Si antes era conocido como
todo un moderado ahora se dedica a
amenazar a diestro y siniestro con el
uso de armas nucleares queréis una
prueba pues fijaos 27 de febrero de 2023
me debe afirma que el suministro de
armas a kiev podría provocar una
catástrofe nuclear mundial 23 de marzo
de 2023 meddebefa afirma que crece La
amenaza de una guerra nuclear Así que
tampoco parece el mejor recambio al
menos para recomponer las relaciones con
occidente y volver así a vender gas y
petróleo Europa como si no hubiera
mañana mientras los grandes oligarcas se
pasean por el mundo billete en mano
luego en términos institucionales el
actual Primer Ministro mijail missoustin
es el siguiente en la línea de Mando sin
embargo procede del servicio Federal de
impuestos es decir que es un tipo al que
Putin colocó en esta posición
precisamente para que gestionar al
gobierno de forma más o menos tecnoc
pero lo cierto Es que no parece tener
mucho capital político así que por ahora
Lo siento mi sustie pero estás
descartado luego habría un nombre que
podría ser toda una sorpresa dentro de
cierta comunidad hablamos de ser gay
quirienko que ya fue Primer Ministro de
Boris gelsin en 1998 actualmente no
tiene Aparentemente Mucho peso político
y ni siquiera tiene un puesto en el
gobierno pero dirige rosatom que es la
empresa Estatal de energía nuclear de la
que ya os hemos hablado aquí en
visualpolitik
a kirillenco se le ve con un perfil más
reformista tiene buenos contactos en
occidente y parece tener también la
simpatía de los altos oficiales de la
inteligencia rusa también tendría buenos
contactos entre muchos de los poderosos
shilobiquis de los que ya os hemos
hablado un montón de veces ya sabéis
políticos y altos funcionarios que
proceden precisamente de las agencias de
seguridad y que hoy forman un anillo de
poder en torno a Putin
[Música]
dicho de otra forma que si los círculos
actuales de poder quisieran mantener el
control de Rusia y al mismo tiempo
lograr dar un cambio que sea capaz de
modernizar el país y mejorar las
relaciones con el resto del mundo este
podría ser su hombre y ojo que cuando
llegó al poder Putin no solo era
relativamente desconocido también llegó
con ese mismo encargo Pues bien Estos
son cuatro de los nombres más destacados
que tenemos que tener en cuenta al menos
tres de ellos pero como hemos dicho
también podría ocurrir que la caída de
Putin fuera provocada por algún
acontecimiento repentino o por la
llegada de un nuevo círculo de poder en
este caso por supuesto el nombre
escogido sería alguien completamente
distinto pero esperad un momento porque
quizás estemos vendiendo la piel de oso
demasiado pronto hay una pregunta que
todavía no nos hemos hecho podría
intentar Putin volver a consolidar su
poder
en cierto modo esta sería otra
alternativa a la situación actual Putin
podría el toro por los cuernos e
intentar consolidar su poder y volver a
ser el Putin al que todos imaginamos
montado encima de un oso sin embargo
para poder hacerlo el líder ruso
necesita dos cosas primero conseguir
acabar con la Guerra de Ucrania sin
sufrir una derrota y segundo lanzar una
enorme purga política al mejor estilo
stalinista Y diréis por qué Pues porque
las purgas no solo sirven para acabar
con discos los y disidentes sino también
para demostrar mano dura abajo así fue
por ejemplo lo que hizo su predecesor
Boris gelsin en 1993 cuando el país
estuvo al borde de la guerra civil
fijaos
en septiembre de 1993 yelsing estaba
contra las cuerdas su gobierno era un
desastre y no estaba siguiendo ninguno
de sus grandes objetivos para cambiar
esta dinámica ordenó disolver el
congreso de los diputados del pueblo de
Rusia y el soviet supremo de Rusia
porque estaban frenando sus reformas
económicas sin embargo el congreso
rechazó el decreto presidencial y por
contra aprobó la destitución del
presidente los legisladores se
atrincheraron en la duma y él sin
respondió utilizando su mejor arma de
negociación El Poder del fuego la duma
fue bombardeada y desalojada por las
fuerzas militares al final yelsing
impuso su voluntad
la situación actual es muy diferente
pero en cierto modo podemos ver un
patrón común si quiere continuar al
frente de Rusia Putin tendrá que dar un
golpe en la mesa es decir acabar con
cualquier disidencia y restablecer su
poder de una forma Clara y visible la
pregunta es será capaz de hacerlo
[Música]
los últimos acontecimientos sugieren que
su posición ya no es tan fuerte el hecho
de que no haya podido castigarla en su
reacción armada de los Wagner Es una muy
buena prueba de ello y ojo porque esta
es una idea muy extendida en la propia
Rusia
26 de junio de 2023 hoy he escuchado la
declaración de pregotzin es
esencialmente un llamamiento a continuar
la rebelión y un intento de presentarse
a sí mismo como un hombre blanco y
tranquilo estoy sorprendido e indignado
por el hecho de que el traidor y Rebelde
sigan libertad y pueda continuar con sus
actividades antiestatales sigue
trabajando para sus enemigos y para la
derrota de Rusia en la guerra Víctor y
mantovich alkins ex miembro del sovit
supremo de la URSS y exdiputado de la
duma estatal de la federación rusa para
colmo todo apunta que la guerra en
Ucrania seguirá castigando su posición
con más y más bajas nuevas derrotas y un
ejército que cada vez estará más harto
del presidente y sus megalómanas ideas
así pues si Putin no ha podido utilizar
todo el poder de su fuerza contra la in
del grupo Wagner no está claro que lo
pueda hacer en un futuro pero a la vez
si no lo hace esto podría acelerar su
caída y llegados a este punto La
pregunta es para vosotros creéis que
Putin logrará dar un golpe en la mesa o
por contra la situación de Rusia hoy se
parece más a la de la unión soviética
del 91 Cómo de cerca pensáis que está el
fin de Putin podéis dejarme vuestra
respuesta en los comentarios y como
siempre no olvidéis Que aquí en
visualpolitik sacamos vídeos nuevos
Todas las semanas así que suscribíos a
este canal y dadle a la campanita para
no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones tampoco olvidéis que
podéis apoyarnos en patreon donde
recibiréis un montón de contenido extra
además de merchandising exclusivo si os
ha gustado este vídeo dadle a like y nos
vemos en el próximo un saludo y hasta
pronto
[Música]